let's start today with a sort of thick
and Meaty policy segment and let's talk
about social security and the context of
this and it's been much requested by
many of you is the absolute apoplexy
from Republicans that the mere
suggestion that over the last few years
they've hinted at and even sometimes
overtly said maybe we should cut Social
Security maybe the cuts would be lower
benefits maybe the cuts would be you
have to work longer meaning raise the
retirement age or whatever the case may
be but when Joe Biden said at his State
of the Union Address a couple of weeks
ago some of these Republicans want to
cut Social Security they went crazy and
started saying Joe Biden is a liar and
we would never do that and on and on and
on and then yesterday on CNBC
incomes former vice president Mike Pence
and he says oh we should definitely put
on the table that we might cut Social
Security and Medicare they've spent
weeks saying we would never do that stop
accusing us of maybe wanting to be open
to considering the possibility
of ever cutting Social Security and
Medicare and then here's Mike Pence
saying oh yeah yeah no like we should
definitely think of that because of the
debt is that well I I respect uh the
speaker's commitment to take Social
Security and Medicare off the table for
the debt ceiling negotiations
we've got to put them on the table in
the long term and right now President
Biden's policy is insolvency I mean
we're we're looking at a debt crisis in
this country over the next 25 years that
is by entitlements and nobody in
Washington D.C wants to talk about it
I've been going around the country I'm
going to continue to try and do my part
yeah
what a heroic thing he's doing what'd
you do about entitlements well I think
first and foremost you have to explain
to people what's going on we got a 32
trillion dollar national debt right now
Andrew
having a national debt the same size as
our nation's economy is unsustainable
last time that happened was right after
well I don't disagree with you I'm just
curious what's on the for you on
entitlements what's on the table well I
think it begins with education it begins
with having the American people
understand yeah so twice like what
exactly would you do well we got to tell
people all about it remember what
happened at the State of the Union Union
when Joe Biden merely suggested some
Republicans
are open to cutting take the economy
hostage I get it unless I agree to their
economic plans
all of you at home should know what
those plans are yeah
instead of making the wealthy pay their
fair share of some Republicans some
Republicans want Medicare and Social
Security Sunset I'm not saying it's a
majority
no
let me give you anybody who doubts it
contact my office I'll give you a copy
of
copy of the proposal and there was you
some Marjory Trader green standing and
screaming so they say for weeks and
weeks no we would never ever ever ever
ever do that and then here goes Mike
Pence and he's like oh yeah it should
absolutely be on the table we have way
too much debt so let's talk about the
truth on this talking point so that we
can all understand what is going on
because the right says Social Security
is insolvent it just doesn't work
financially it doesn't work here's the
truth and the truth is it's
it's a good thing and a bad thing that
it's really clear what's going on
because sometimes when things are so
clear and simple the right loves to
pretend like they're really complicated
despite Republicans claiming Social
Security is insolvent meaning unable to
pay the benefits that it owes or will
owe people if we do nothing we change
nothing at all about social security
there is enough money to pay full
benefits until 2035 that means like if
you keep doing just the inflation
adjustments for cost of living to what
people get you change nothing about what
people in other than continuing to do
the inflation adjustment to the Social
Security Catholic literally nothing
changes until 2040 2035 there is no
problem and if we continue with the do
nothing scenario starting in 2035 you
can reduce benefits to 80 of what they
would be inflation adjusted and then it
still continues to be fine making no
changes whatsoever other than moving
benefits from 100 to 80 percent
now what is the reason that this is
going on why is this even a conversation
changing demographics more and more
people are retiring relative to the
number of workers so as Baby Boomers
continue to retire the number of people
receiving benefits relative to the
number of people paying in is going to
fall uh out of balance towards the
retirees and then secondly people on
average are living longer meaning that
the estimates for how long people are
going to be receiving benefits it's more
years because people are living longer
okay now I think it's unacceptable
to go down to 80 of benefits but again
with doing nothing
fine until 2035 and then fine for a very
long time on 80 of benefits I believe if
you've paid in based on getting a
hundred percent of benefits you should
get them okay but I've laid out the
do-nothing scenario it's not exactly
insolvent is it it's everything's fine
for 11 12 years and then we do a 20
reduction but let's fix it okay how do
we fix it there's quite a few ways
they're relatively simple it's just a
matter of finding the political will to
do it as a reminder right now in 2023
Social Security contributions are made
on your first hundred and sixty thousand
dollars that you earn per year okay once
you get Beyond 160 you stop paying into
Social Security the amount that is paid
in is 12.4 percent now many of you might
say David it I'm only paying 6.2 percent
the reason is that in a normal job if
you're a W-2 employee that uh 12.4
percent is divided between you and your
employer so instead of you paying 12.4
percent you pay 6.2 your employer pays
6.2 if you're self-employed like me you
pay the full 12.4 okay so what can you
do one thing you can do is you can
increase that rate you could say instead
of 12.4 percent it's going to be
something higher on that first hundred
and sixty thousand dollars I don't like
that idea because it disproportionately
hits those earning under a hundred and
sixty thousand but you could do do that
you could say instead of 12.4 percent
we're going to pay 15 and that's going
to stretch out how long we can pay a
hundred percent of benefits second
option you can raise the cap so you keep
it at 12.4 percent
but instead of paying that on your first
hundred and sixty thousand that you make
maybe you paid on your first 180 or
maybe on your first 200. that seems like
a better option to me number three you
could raise the retirement age it's very
controversial I don't like it but you
could say well you've got to wait longer
before you can get benefits what I do
like is giving a bonus if you delay
retirement by choice this is already
part of the way it works and for people
for whom this is new I think it's useful
to know this stuff right now you can
start receiving reduced benefits at age
62. the standard age to get benefits is
67. so your 100 benefit would be if you
say at 67 years of age I want to start
getting the benefits from 62 to 67 you
get less and if you at age 67 say I
don't need the money yet either because
I have private retirement or I'm going
to continue working or whatever if you
say I'm going to wait until I'm 68 or 69
or 70 you get even more benefits when
you do retire we could expand that and
say hey you know what people are living
longer and many people would gladly
delay getting their social security
benefits you could say if you choose to
wait until age 71 or 72 or 73 or 74 you
get more benefits which leaves money in
the trust fund than a kind of crew
earnings and gains you don't force
anybody to do anything but you give an
option that's interesting a fourth
option is to move the money in the
Social Security trust fund to something
with potentially higher return but with
more risk right now Social Security
invests in low-risk government bonds
very safe very low return without going
into we're going to buy Bitcoin you
could slightly expand the list of
investment vehicles that social
securities trust fund can be invested in
with the idea that there will be a
little more uh volatility but over time
you should get a higher return and that
could close that Gap that will
eventually appear and then lastly you
could also increase immigration bring in
people to work to pay into the system in
order to even out that ratio so we can
fix this with some tweaks you could
raise the cap a little bit and then you
could offer greater benefits to people
who choose to delay retirement a little
more
increase immigration a little bit to
increase the number of people paying in
and consider slightly higher yield but
slightly higher risk Investments with
some of the money it's not brain surgery
but it's a political gridlock and we
have the solutions if only we could get
our elected officials to put them in
place
lastly mixing this specific issue of the
Social Security trust fund generally
with that of the national debt is also
very dishonest because the truth is
social security is its own trust fund
and we can manage and make tweaks to
that individually the conversation about
the debt is fine but it really is a
separate conversation so after weeks of
saying we would never do that Mike Pence
shows up and says oh yeah yeah we should
definitely consider that Ron DeSantis
recently pulled the publicity stunt in
Chicago and the governor of the state of
Illinois where Chicago is didn't like it
and he's firing back and firing back
viciously what happened is that Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis in what appears to
be a pre-presidential run announcement
tour has been going he went to Staten
Island he also went to Chicago and he
spoke to the Fraternal Order of Police
Lodge number seven on Monday night in
Elmhurst which is a suburb of Chicago
and at that event Ron DeSantis went
after JB pritzker the Democratic
governor of Illinois
for his criminal justice policies saying
the safety act and other Illinois
policies are the wokification of Public
Safety now this is an incredibly
inaccurate Claim by Ron DeSantis but JB
pritzker who does not mess around
viciously but accurately attacked Ron
DeSantis take a look at this the truth
is that we we actually have a much
better education system in Illinois than
they have true in Florida we're ranked
higher than they are yes U.S news and
World Report ranks K-12 education in
Illinois sixth in the country and number
one among the largest states in the
country yeah
thank you
so he's got nothing to brag about when
it comes to education so uh so he moves
on and tries to use this word woke to
describe everything he doesn't even know
what the word means and he has no
definition of it it's just anything he
doesn't like is wokism true and all I
can tell you is that I don't know what
that means and frankly uh what I can say
about Illinois is that we're a state
that cares about Equity or a state that
cares about our families that's woke
caring about your family and Equity
that's what he means by woke sir making
the Investments that are required so
that our youngest children will do
better and better and I'm really excited
about the direction of our state as
opposed to a state where they don't make
the Investments that are necessary to
lift up their education system or their
Health Care system so pritzker is of
course completely correct now the tough
talk from pritzker is being suggested
could be because he's planning
potentially to run for president if
Biden doesn't run or maybe even if he
does it's sort of unclear but pritzker's
name has kind of been floating around as
a possible Contender but put that aside
for a second okay
the truth is that even if you put aside
education where Illinois is light years
ahead of Florida that's absolutely the
case put aside talk about the primary
subject matter here remember DeSantis
was speaking to police about law
enforcement and so on and so forth the
Wright loves to talk about the dystopian
war zone that is Illinois because of
Chicago specifically and it's absolutely
true that Chicago does have a
significant gang and gun crime issue
we've talked about how easy it is by the
way to go over the border into Indiana
40 minutes and then go back with uh guns
that you can easily obtain in Indiana
we've talked but put that put all of
that aside for a second despite Florida
having the lacks gun laws and laws that
give police more latitude and all these
different things and despite the
allegation that Illinois is just so
backwards on crime the reality is that
Illinois and Florida have really similar
violent crime rates they have different
populations but if you look at per
capita violent crime it's something like
it's 390 per hundred thousand people in
Florida and 420 per 100 000 people in
Illinois yes Illinois has a slightly
higher violent crime rate but the truth
is they're both right in the middle
around the 2025 you know out of 50
states so to put it a different way
even though if you ask Ron DeSantis
Florida's doing everything right on
crime law enforcement and guns and
Illinois is doing everything wrong on
crime law enforcement and guns they have
almost identical violent crime rates
which really makes you wonder
is Ron DeSantis really doing everything
right is JB pritzker really doing
anything wrong because those are pretty
damn weak numbers to demonstrate that
that's the case good for JB pritzker I
like the guy I am not as familiar with
him as as on policy as I could be but he
has always struck me as decent and
willing to use the sort of language
rhetoric and tone against these lying
Republicans that I think we need more of
and that we've seen from only only a
handful of prominent Democrats let's
take a very quick break all of the clips
I played for you here will be on our
YouTube channel at youtube.com the
davidpackman show and they will also be
on the Spanish YouTube channel for those
who prefer the Spanish language version
of this show
at davidpackman.com Spanish
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
a single very strange woman
may be jeopardizing what could be a
coming Trump indictment out of the
Georgia grand jury that ended its work a
few weeks ago let me set this up and
this is this is weird and cringy and
just bizarre
um one of the members of the grand jury
in Georgia that recently finished its
work issued its report and apparently
some indictments are coming although we
don't yet know whether Trump himself is
going to be indicted has been on a very
strange media tour that I can't imagine
is useful to anybody other than maybe
herself she is uh named Emily cores and
she was the foreperson of this grand
jury in Georgia
she has been going around giving
cringy interviews speaking in a bizarre
way and I don't know if you know uh I
just don't know what the I don't know
what why everything about this woman is
so strange but she is according to Legal
experts potentially
jeopardizing the indictment of Donald
Trump we're going to play a first clip
here from MSNBC her demeanor is bizarre
it's cringy it's strange but most
importantly this could really be I mean
the the giddiness and even just I listen
under the best of circumstances this
probably isn't a good idea before
indictments are announced but in
particular her demeanor and her
giddiness and everything about it is
it's not helping anybody other than
maybe Trump did you personally want to
hear from the formula I wanted to hear
from the former president but honestly I
kind of wanted to subpoena the former
president because I got to swear
everybody in and so I thought it'd be
really cool to get 60 seconds with
President Trump of me looking at him and
being like do you solemnly swear I'm
beginning to swear him in I just I kind
of just thought that would be
oh my God this is this is very much not
good guys this is very very much not
good awesome moment I can see it would
have been awesome not indicated by the
facts not necessary uh out of a sense of
Duty and Justice it would have been
really cool and awesome to subpoena
Trump oh trying to get the former
president to come talk to us would have
been
a year in negotiation by itself so it
sounds like that was ultimately a battle
that you all decided not to wait exactly
that's that's kind of how it ended up
was that
I'd be fascinated by what he said but
do you think he would have come in and
said anything groundbreaking or just the
same kind of thing we've heard
so at some point you don't need to hear
50 people say the same thing you know
what I mean at some point you kind of
start to get the gist
um
then she went on CNN and it was an
equally bizarre interview
you know it's interest ingly that just
raises more questions I know I know I'm
sorry no no do please do not apologize
I'm very appreciative of your time when
you say there's no plot twists and you
know people won't be shocked people are
gonna people are gonna hear that and
they're gonna think that means that
Donald Trump is definitely on that list
um
I know it's delicate but can you can you
speak to that I can't
well I understand I might be able to
according to instructions but I don't
want to I don't want to speak out on
something that the judge like I said
consciously chose not to release at this
point I don't know if I would interfere
with the DA's investigations I don't
know if I would interfere with
procedures in some way I just I very
much do not want to cross that line but
in your view people will not be
surprised when they see the list of
names to come out who you recommended to
face indictment especially if they've
been following the investigation
I I can't see it being a shocker
you know Donald Trump put up this is
just such a terrible idea statement last
week about the partial report that the
judge did release the pages that he did
and the way that he described it is he
said that yet your report means total
exoneration for him is how he put it in
his statement what's your reaction to
that Emily
um
I did see that today uh which was
fascinating I'm not
positive he read the right document
but um
I will say that if what he was talking
about was our statement where we
indicated that there was no evidence of
widespread fraud or widespread vote
fraud in the Georgia 2020 election
that might have been what he meant
other than that I'm not positive what he
meant by that so anyway as fascinating
as this is uh this is potentially a
really really really bad thing and here
on CNN our former federal and state
prosecutor Eli honig explaining it all
to Anderson Cooper for spectrum now from
CNN senior legal analyst Ali honig
former assistant U.S attorney he's also
the author of the new book Untouchable
how powerful people get away with it
also with us our chief political
correspondent and co-anchor of CNN's
State of the Union Dana Bash
um first of all why this person is
talking on TV I do not understand she's
clearly enjoying herself yeah um but I
mean is this responsible she was the
four person of this grand jury this is a
horrible idea and I guarantee you that
prosecutors are wincing watching her go
on this I was wincing just watching her
eagerness to like you know hint at stuff
it's painful in that respect this is a
very serious Prospect here we're talking
about indicting any person you're
talking about potentially taking away
that person's Liberty we're talking
about potentially a former president for
the first time in this nation's history
she does not seem to be taking that very
seriously there's no reason for her to
be out talking no there's none right
it's a prosecutor's nightmare mark my
words Donald Trump's team is going to
make a motion if there's an indictment
to dismiss that indictment based on
grand jury impropriety she's not
supposed to be talking about anything
really but she's really not supposed to
be talking about the deliberations she's
talking about what specific Witnesses
they saw what the grand jury thought of
so you get the picture now a couple
people a couple of you emailed me and
said David is it possible that she is
pretending and playing a character in
order to derail the entire thing I don't
know everything about this is so weird
that the truth could be anything Trump
already launching an attack on her on
his platform truth social posting quote
this Georgia case is ridiculous a
strictly political continuation of the
greatest Witch Hunt of all time now you
have an extremely energetic young woman
the get this four person of the racist
da special grand jury going around and
doing a media tour revealing incredibly
the grand jury's inner workings and
thoughts this is not just this this is
an illegal Kangaroo Court Atlanta's the
leading the nation in murder and other
violent crimes all I did is make two
perfect phone calls now not everybody's
reactions to this this or sane Charlie
Kirk for example said that the woman is
a witch yeah it's really funny someone
might go to jail and have to spend
hundreds of thousands of dollars to
defend themselves
but that warrants a giggle now maybe
that was just a nervous giggle because
you're in front of millions of people
making a complete fool out of yourself
and now we learn about her love of
alchemy no joke she posts on her social
media page about herbs about casting a
circle demonic circles how to cast
spells not a joke this is all on her
social media page yeah now this is why
you don't go out and do a media tour so
I hope that this doesn't derail whatever
was coming I hope it's not used in the
future as Ellie honig suggests for a
dismissal but this is a very very bad
idea and now all we can do is wait
uh 2024 candidate Donald Trump went to
East Palestine Ohio yesterday and held
an event the event was completely
deranged Trump talked about football
Trump brought Trump water
he went to a McDonald's he told people
to have fun and the entire event was a
complete and total farce that went
horribly wrong right away in this first
clip Trump falsely claims that the Biden
Administration intends to do nothing
about what took place in Ohio but that
his presence there got them to all of a
sudden start doing things that's what it
is this is really America right here
we're standing in America unfortunately
as you know in too many cases your
goodness and perseverance who were met
with indifference and betrayal in some
cases
Biden and FEMA said they would not send
federal aid to
East Palestine under any
circumstance they're not going to send
Aid I thought that was a strange
statement because I've been working with
FEMA for a long time four years and they
were great with us with the tornadoes
the hurricanes and things like this and
it was a strange statement to come out
and they were doing nothing for you they
were
intending to do absolutely nothing for
you JD and I spoke and they said they're
not coming they're not going to come and
I said that's very strange FEMA said
specifically this doesn't meet the
criteria and that's horrible and
somebody has to do something for those
people I said back when I announced that
I was coming they changed their tune it
was an amazing phenomena the mayor and I
were discussing that it was quite
amazing what happened and yeah they said
that we can't let this happen
that was a big change of face JD did you
ever see a change like that one that was
a quick yep as you know of course Trump
has an unblemished record as the beacon
of corporate responsibility and is just
the perfect person to really uh turn to
on this issue and hold big corporations
accountable now nothing that he's saying
there is true but he does have to make
himself the center of attention Trump
also says that he brought Trump water
for people even though when we research
it it seems like Trump water hasn't
actually been a thing for a very long
time but what it seems like it is is
Trump gets labels for some other water
and just puts them on it's all crazy but
he says he brought Trump water for
people in East Palestine but he also
brought like lower Quality Water for
them as well in case some people don't
want the Great Water I guess I don't
know especially thanks some of the
incredible people that helped us because
we're bringing thousands of bottle of
water Trump order actually across the
water some of it we had to go to a much
lesser quality water
you want to get those Trump bottles I
think more than anybody else but we're
bringing a lot of he brought good water
and he also brought lower Quality Water
for people
absolutely Beyond parody the reality of
course in terms of Trump's record on
train regulations is that there were
safety rules put in place by the Obama
Administration for high Hazard cargo
trains which Trump then said oh Obama
did that Obama yes Obama then I'm going
to go ahead and repeal those and that is
exactly what took place Trump then
started ranting about football if you
can believe it you know it reminded me a
little bit I don't know if you remember
when Ohio State wasn't going to be
playing football for another season they
were going to sit back and watch with
the China virus or covet whatever you
want to call it
and I called the head of the Big Ten Big
Ten football I said you got to get this
football open
and they were great they responded and
Ohio State played that season now the
Big Ten denies that Trump had any
involvement in this but it is one of
those stories that Trump loves to repeat
nobody remembers that I think right does
anybody because it didn't happen you
know you got at least one at least one
you could be close but by now you still
would be close probably but we got that
open very early and you had a great
season of football yep all thanks to
Trump of course and then lastly even
though Trump is obese he makes a fat
joke about East Palestine mayor Trent
Conaway saying that he's very easy to
find because he's overweight right so
how could you possibly miss him I also
want to recognize a man who has been
working tirelessly for this community
since the beginning of the Nightmare and
uh Trent where is Trent he's very easy
to find
I do think Trump doesn't see himself as
obese because he so frequently talks
about other people's weight and size uh
while claiming to be 6'3 and weighing
only 239 which uh oh God what is
happening in this country so anyway
there is Trump's very inspiring visit to
East Palestine taking credit for things
he didn't do ignoring his own role in
reducing train regulations uh calling
the mayor fat and then going to
McDonald's and
um I don't know handing out Maga hats as
he did another horrible embarrassment
you can find these clips if you're
morbidly curious about what this all
looked like we'll have these clips up on
our Instagram which you can find by
searching Instagram for David packman
show they'll be on Facebook at
facebook.com davidpackman show and of
course on the YouTube channel at
youtube.com slash the davidpackman and
show
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show it's great
to welcome back to the program today
Kelly Weil who's a reporter at The Daily
Beast and also author of off the edge
flat earthers conspiracy culture and why
people will believe anything uh Kelly
great to have you back on I appreciate
your time
thanks so much for having me again so
when you were last on about a year ago
we talked a lot about how people fall
into conspiratorial thinking how
sometimes seemingly benign conspiracy
theories don't sort of stand alone and
they're often wrapped up with other
beliefs that can be more damaging we
talked a little bit about how we can get
people to maybe revise some of their
thinking over the last year we've seen
Twitter in particular change
dramatically in terms of its enforcement
and application of terms of service
under the stewardship of its new owner
Elon Musk and that certainly had impacts
we've also seen platforms like Facebook
and YouTube slightly change if not their
policies at least the way that they
implement or police the terms of service
around conspiratorial or
non-science-based content how would you
kind of characterize big picture the
direction that things have gone in these
areas over over the last year
it's a good question I think big Tech
broadly has been stepping away from some
of the misinformation fears that really
characterized around the 2020
presidential elections and you know I
want to give them some credit in the
past but also not too much credit
because
around that election I think a lot of
them were more cognizant of what they
needed to do to combat misinformation
but they weren't doing the best job of
it I think uh some of the best work that
they did to keep the platforms from
going totally off the rails had to do
with uh combating algorithms that they
had that prioritize conspiratorial
content I'm thinking mostly of YouTube
which had uh you know recommendations
that put the weirdest stuff at the top
of your feed and although that still
happens to their credit they have taken
action against some of the really
Bonkers stuff it's harder to find Flat
Earth accidentally for example but now
we're kind of swinging back in that same
direction
um you uh pardon me Twitter has this new
for you feed it's a total ripoff of The
Tick Tock for you for it is uh you know
guessing what you want to see often you
know our worst impulses do Drive what we
want to see we do want to see the weird
stuff the conspiratorial stuff the stuff
that you're clicking on it to in the
morning so um I do think we are seeing a
maybe a bit laxer rules on how things
are promoted and distributed on social
media yeah there seems to be sort of
like an air of we're really not going to
be able to stop this and maybe it really
shouldn't even be our responsibility at
the end of the day that seems to have I
don't know if it started when musk took
over Twitter and kind of spread from
there but there seems to be less of a
concern with this
um at least among what I'm hearing
publicly from many of the platforms
yeah absolutely I think there's sort of
a learned how listens there because I do
broadly think that it's true you know
social media platforms can't administer
away all the conspiratorial thinking you
know that's a very human drive we have
it's not going to change if Facebook
were to vanish off the face of the Earth
Tomorrow nor really do they think should
they be involved in litigating the you
know minutia of what we share but there
are very deliberate decisions that some
of these social media leaders are uh
taking Elon Musk you look at who he
interacts with and these are people who
came out of like gamer gate blogs right
these are former alt-right conspiracy
mongers and so there's a difference
between saying well you know maybe we'll
be a little bit more libertarian with
how we police things maybe we'll let
things you know hang a little bit looser
and Elon Musk going and like sharing the
weirdest stuff that you'd normally find
on 4chan and you know saying huh
interesting anyone looking into that so
you know it's uh they're not completely
as helpless as sometimes they portray
themselves elves the anti-vaxx issue has
gotten interesting over the last year
because over time the truth about what
the vaccines do and don't do for the
latest variants has changed and this is
being used by some anti-vaxxers
including those described in a recent
Vice motherboard piece as now wanting
Revenge so-called Revenge because they
feel that they've been Vindicated this
has become a tough one because to take
something as simple as does the vaccine
prevent you from getting the virus when
we go back to that first vaccine and the
first variant the data was very clear
that it did prevent you from getting and
spreading the virus there were people
then saying no it doesn't over time as
the variants have changed and the
vaccine has been updated it's primarily
a tool to prevent you from dying or
ending up in the hospital but now it is
a different reality about whether it
prevents you from getting the virus
things have changed in the real world
the anti-vaxxers have been saying the
same thing for three years it now more
closely lines up with what they were
saying all along that's a really
difficult situation to handle
so challenging and I think it gets at a
reason conspiracy theories are so potent
the reason that we can all fall for them
is because conspiracy theories you know
there's something that we activate when
we do have uncertainty when we don't
have all the informations when something
is frightening in front of us and
conspiracy theories often latch onto a
kernel of Truth or at least a an
emotional truth right and the truth here
is that the vaccines they're not perfect
you know they will keep you out of the
hospital they will make it harder for
you to catch and spread you know this
virus but like you said as the virus
mutates vaccines have been you know
playing catch up and while it is
absolutely a phenomenal idea for people
to get their vaccines get their boosters
it's not going to be the miracle cure
that uh you know we're really hoping for
I want to say like summer of 2020 and so
anti-vaxxers who to your point have
always been saying that you can't take
the vaccine it's you know it's it's
garbage or it's going to hurt you
they've had to kind of tailor their
messaging and say well okay not
everybody dropped dead three months
after getting the vaccine it's not it's
not the zombie apocalypse that we warned
about but it's not working perfectly and
so they take this new reality and they
retrofit it onto what they were saying
to say well you shouldn't have taken the
vaccines and you know I think to that
point about revenge they certainly some
of them I think do uh kind of yearn for
a future where all their political
opponents drop dead because they got the
backs yeah
um as we've seen the media discussions
of covid more generally
um reduced we also seem to see a little
bit less about Ivermectin and
hydroxychloroquine and urine injections
or nebulizing or whatever you know I'm
sure you saw that guy
um what is what is kind of filling the
void right now I mean I see they're get
they're talking more about Hunter Biden
laptop even though that's a different
sort of thing it's not really equivalent
to you know Ivermectin what what new
things over the last six months are you
seeing getting more oxygen
well I think we're seeing a lot of uh I
hate to say that like Republican cope
with the uh 2022 uh midterms you know a
lot of people not accepting that their
uh their party really didn't sweep the
way they expected so this is going to be
a you know relitigation of 2020 election
fraud hoaxes I'm seeing a good number of
environmental conspiracy theories uh
percolating right now we just had the
train derailment in East Palestine that
of course was the result of you know
huge bipartisan lapses and labor rights
and uh in Transportation laws and you
know the way that these railroads can
lobby but because this is a frightening
situation where it is true our
politicians don't really have the
answers we've seen this void where the
right can step in and say that this is a
plot against you either you know that
they I don't know the the left is
covering up for this or that you know
it's a deliberate sabotage of the
Midwest of of uh Food Supplies that are
really on to that right now this idea
that uh Democrats are gonna like you
know nuke Amish country or something
like that so it's uh I think that's
really powerful and that comes I think
in uh side by side with other conspiracy
theories right now that are uh really
hitting back at the idea that you should
be polluting less uh they're really up
in arms right now about the idea of the
15-minute City the idea that you can
walk uh you know you don't need a car
you can walk to the things you need your
child's School the supermarket
um and they're you know calling that a
new world order plot to suppress people
so we I think are seeing a lot of
conspiracy theories that try and um fit
in more conservative ideology into the
reality of this moment where we are
facing fraud and frightening
environmental reality so I think that's
going to be a trend going forward the
other one recently has been the the
quote spy balloon
um and of course I mean anytime you get
anywhere even remotely close to aliens
all sorts of folks come out of the
woodwork but so I don't know if I can
say surprisingly but someone said
surprisingly you're seeing some of that
come even from marginally more serious
people like are we sure that this isn't
alien life or whatever the case may be
it ended up being a topic
um for Biden's press secretary Kareem
Jean-Pierre talking about it a bunch of
times has anything surprised you in what
we've seen related to the balloons
you know actually yes and maybe it
speaks to a quaint idea of conspiracy
theorists that we still hold where
they're the ones with the tinfoil hats
try to talk to aliens in their backyard
when we got this uh this trending topic
this idea that there were UFOs that we
were interacting with I'm like okay well
at least we're gonna have some vintage
conspiracy theories we're gonna have
some aliens weirdly enough people didn't
latch on so much to the idea that these
were you know aliens trying to
communicate with us which it doesn't
seem like they were it was you know
often hobbyists balloons are being shot
down but that the balloons were actually
a distraction from something else oh
this were a plot they were trying to
distract you from uh the East Palestine
derailment they're trying to distract
you from reporting on um on a Russian
oil pipeline so it was really
interesting to see the emergence of
something that in the past I think kind
of classic conspiracy fodder and it
wasn't enough in this moment it wasn't
the red meat the conspiracy theorists
were looking for that's another
interesting trait of a lot of these
conspiracy theories you know last time
you and I talked about how
apparent evidence in favor of a
conspiracy theory can be just as useful
as the absence of evidence because the
absence of evidence becomes part of the
conspiracy so it becomes kind of
unfalsifiable in the same way an event
can be
an event you are being lied to and not
told the truth about or the conspiracy
can be the event is real but it's
fundamentally a distraction from some
other thing and it's another aspect of
the sort of unfalsifiability of a lot of
these things
I think that's absolutely right you know
one thing that I struggle with as a
journalist I think a lot of journalists
have this frustration is the idea that
you'll see it on Facebook people say why
isn't this being covered why isn't it
covered and in some respects I think we
do have to take that seriously if people
if people feel like the reality they're
living isn't reflected uh adequately in
the news I think that is something that
we need to take into account but
oftentimes they're saying why isn't this
being covered and you say what and they
link to a CNN article right absolutely
blows my mind but to your point I think
um you know this this idea that you can
you know touch on the apparent lack of
coverage and say that this is indicative
of a cover-up or this is you know
suggestive of another plot really does
show the the flexibility of these
theories uh you know it allows people to
um take their perceived uh the media
that they're taking in and say that it's
part of a broader plot but it's part of
a broader effort to distract you or to
uh steer you in a certain direction and
I think uh a lot of especially a lot of
alternative media folks have really
become quite Adept at taking what the
news media is putting out and saying
that it's part of a distraction effort
or it's part of a you know a a broader
scheme yeah even just the coverage
itself aside from this is the real story
or not or whatever the case may be if
you perceive or claim there isn't
coverage the lack of coverage is part of
the conspiracy and if there's a lot of
coverage then it must be a concerted
effort to talk about that as opposed to
the thing which really should be
discussed so even the amount of coverage
can be used
absolutely again it's it's a real
frustration you know ironically right
now
reporting on East Palestine and someone
I'm talking to you says yeah we're
getting swamped by grifters on the
ground we've got Benny Johnson's on the
ground who are running around filming
videos and look I think you know
fundamentally there doesn't need to be a
lot of Aid there I think people are
rightly uh happy to be getting donations
and stuff like that but you you it's
very easy to turn these things into a
circus over the amount of perceived
coverage or lack thereof or people's uh
imputed agendas when what's really going
on is an environmental crisis with you
know a pretty traceable backstory as to
how it happened yeah even as I receive
emails from people saying it's not
getting coverage I'm realizing
everybody's emailing me about the fact
that it's not getting coverage it's on
CNN it's on Fox News it's in the
Washington Post New York Times
alternative media the story about the
coverage seems to take on a life of its
own
it really does um and you know I could
speculate a couple reasons why one is
you know I think uh regardless of
political orientation I think we do have
an ambient anxiety about the environment
we know something's up and then you see
something just as uh as shocking as that
big great plume of smoke and that really
grabs attention I think you know the
East Palestine derailment also speaks to
a sort of uh forgotten uh class
narrative that I think uh the right has
become very Adept at wielding without
actually addressing the underlying
issues
um Trump went to East Palestine just
this week when we're speaking um and he
understands that that is you know
predominantly white working collar uh
community that that does often
constitute his base and even though some
of the solutions that could help that
Community you know
immediate donations now but also you
know longer term investments in Social
programs that would help and that are
very often a progressive or liberal
programs it's
having a town like that at the heart of
such a striking uh incident it does kind
of feed into this idea that these are
people who are being left behind in a
way that conservatives can help but
liberals can that's a really interesting
uh interpretation as well which which uh
makes a lot of sense
um the book is now in paperback off the
edge flat earthers conspiracy culture
and why people will believe anything
we've been speaking with the book's
author reporter at The Daily Beast Kelly
Weil Kelly always appreciate your time
and insights
thank you so much for having me
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
well Jared Kushner and Ivanka Trump have
now been subpoenaed by these special
counsel and this is a very very big deal
which potentially will lead simply to
hundreds of times over many hours
pleading the fifth depending on how it
goes the New York Times reports Jared
Kushner and Ivanka Trump subpoenaed in
January 6th investigation now you might
be saying David sir hold on I thought
that ended because Congress ended this
is not that investigation the last
Congressional term ended better said and
now Republicans have taken over this is
not that investigation this is the
special counsel the article says the
special counsel overseeing the inquiry
into Trump's efforts to retain power
after the 2020 election once the former
president's daughter and son-in-law to
testify to a grand jury
the decision by the special counsel Jack
Smith to subpoena Trump and Kushner
underscores How Deeply into Trump's
Inner Circle Smith is reaching and is
the latest sign that no potential
high-level witness is off limits the
article also says the disclosure about
the subpoena comes two weeks after it
was revealed that Smith subpoenaed
former vice president Pence Pence plans
to fight that subpoena invoking his role
as president of the Senate to argue that
it violates the speech or debate clause
of the Constitution as far as these
subpoenas go quote it is unclear whether
Trump will seek to block whether Donald
Trump will seek to block Ivanka Trump
and Jared Kushner from testifying on the
grounds of executive privilege as he has
tried with some other Witnesses both of
them served as White House officials in
the Trump Administration Trump declined
to try to stop them from testifying
before the house committee an aid to
Ivanka and Jared didn't respond with a
request for for comment it's ironic like
how the Trump cult
often overlooks
how Jared Kushner received billions from
Saudi Arabia which is a country they
love to demonize but they're obsessed
about Hunter Biden's laptop and Jared
Kushner who admittedly we don't talk
about that often on this program either
he and Ivanka seem to have kind of
decided for our personal image this
entire thing was very bad and there are
articles about how you know in the
waning days of the Trump Administration
they wanted to just kind of like return
to their old social lives in New York
City and a lot of people didn't want to
welcome them because they were
understandably disgusted so they ended
up I think it was like moving to Miami
but the it's a whole mess but Jared and
Ivanka or at least somewhat connected to
the reality of how they are now seen and
the truth is that they don't get the
scrutiny that they probably deserve as
individuals who were far more involved
with the Trump Administration than were
Eric and Don Jr for example and the
double standard with the hunter Biden
laptop is of course wild and we
reasonable people could point to them
and say you know they made hundreds of
millions of dollars while serving for
the government thanks to nepotism
and somehow that doesn't deserve an
investigation but hunter Biden when we
know 99 of the hunter Biden's story and
his drug issues and the entire thing he
had nothing to do with government he had
nothing to do with Joe Biden's vice
presidency he has nothing to do with Joe
Biden's presidency they want extensive
investigations and hearings and endless
resources and millions of dollars of
taxpayer money going to the hunter Biden
laptop but they're not even thinking
about Jared Jared and Ivanka
um one of the things I do think however
about Ivanka my instinct right now given
the distance that Ivanka and Jared have
kind of put between themselves and
Trump's 2024 campaign
Ivanka has kids that I think she
actually does care about
um I think she would throw her dad under
the bus if it meant saving herself and
her family the most likely outcome at
the end of this entire subpoena is an
eight-hour deposition where Ivanka
pleads the fifth 500 or a thousand times
I still think that's the most likely
outcome but if it really came down to
self-preservation I actually do think
that Ivanka would do what she needed to
do to maintain her immediate family unit
um but that's just a guess let me know
what you think in the comments Fox News
continues to try to thread this needle
where they want to do what they can to
make someone other than Trump the
Republican nominee in 2024 but Fox
doesn't want to go off the deep end off
the diving board so to speak in case
Trump ends up being the nominee so some
of the things Fox News has done to
subtly and softly push voters and public
opinion towards Rhonda Sanders include
they'll do a man on the street segment
and it just so happens that 10 of the 11
people they talk to say I would rather
DeSantis be the nominee than Trump now
of course you can talk to as many people
as you need to until you get enough to
create the narrative that you want and
the narrative that fox chose to create
was let's make these men on the street
segments overwhelmingly point to
Republican voters who prefer DeSantis
over Trump uh they have been giving more
sort of serious positive coverage or at
least neutral coverage to DeSantis
events than they have to Trump events
okay the latest thing is that they are
straight up running like a Ron DeSantis
propaganda special here's the promo for
it take a look
Fox Nations hit docu series is back who
is Ron DeSantis we will never ever
surrender to the woke mob
he was in the Middle East advising Seal
Team One to advise them you have to be
the best of the best he's a good man
he's a good husband he's a good father
is this Ron desantis's opportunity to
run for higher office I think it is who
is Rhonda Santos streaming now only on
Fox Nation yeah so anyway remember what
Angelo caruson told us about this Fox
News primarily wants to be adjacent to
power and because it's not yet clear
that Donald Trump isn't going to be the
nominee Fox News needs to continue at
least plausibly setting themselves up to
fully jump back on on the Trump train if
Trump is indeed the nominee and if there
are potentially going to be another four
years of a trump Administration however
Rupert Murdoch doesn't think much of
trump and it's very clear from the
released text messages that we got last
week that many of the Fox News hosts
don't really think much of trump at
least as far as his level of honesty
this includes Laura Ingram Sean Hannity
Tucker Etc who knew Trump was lying all
along about the big lie and and the
entire thing so as Angelo told us when I
interviewed him Angelo carriesone from
Media Matters Fox News wants to do what
it can to push voters to Ron DeSantis or
to anybody so that Trump is less likely
to be the nominee but
they need to have a sort of eject button
right they need to have a an escape pod
to get back to Trump and not completely
sever that relationship because Trump is
such a sycophant and he loves uh because
Trump is such a sycophant lover and he
loves suck-ups
even though Trump is now criticizing Fox
News as being the Rhino Network and all
of this different stuff if he is the
nominee and if fox goes right back to
him and you know is eating out of his
hand and whatever Trump will go right
back to doing the prime time Fox News
interviews in the entire thing because
Trump loves the attention as well it's a
sort of symbiosis of narcissism and
um a symbiosis of narcissism and uh an
obsession with power that is going to
keep that relationship going if indeed
Trump is the nominee but for the time
being subtly but increasingly less
subtly Fox News is doing what it can
to hope that and and influence the
Republican primary towards someone other
than Trump right now based on the
polling the best Contender of course
would be Ron DeSantis and speaking of
that polling uh we we've got a few
recent polls there is a co-efficient
poll which has DeSantis uh up 33 over
Larry Hogan and Trump up 27 over Larry
Hogan so so like the Santa's performing
slightly better than Trump against Hogan
but DeSantis versus Trump DeSantis is
leading by four however in a multi-way
race if you do Trump DeSantis Hogan
Nikki Haley Mike Pence Mike Pompeo Tim
Scott that's better for Trump and that
is the trend in every single one of
these polls when the polls include more
than just Trump versus DeSantis Trump
tends to lead when the polls are just
Trump versus DeSantis it's much better
for DeSantis in general so that can
continues to be a trend that of course
we are going to follow we have a
voicemail number that number is 2192
David P
continued confusion folks
am I a socialist
or not I am not a socialist but the
confusion continues
hi David this is lokesh I'm from Atlanta
Georgia well I want to ask you
to call yourself a Social Democrat a
couple years ago yeah and I wanted to
ask what label best describes to
politics now in 2022 thanks have a nice
day bye-bye okay it's actually 2023 with
all due respect I know we're all making
that same mistake it's I'm still doing
the yeah anyway
um I this might come as a shock I am
still a Social Democrat social democracy
being a well-regulated form of
capitalism I am still there
and uh
yeah I don't the confusion about my
politics has certainly increased lately
but I am still not a socialist and I
know there are people waiting anxiously
for that to happen but for the time
being I am still a Social Democrat we
have a great bonus show for you today
Texas has a bill which would ban nearly
all gender affirming care including for
transgender adults adults who are
supposedly able to make the decisions
that they believe are best for them
lawyers for Donald Trump propaganda
Steve Bannon
are now suing Bannon over legal bills
Apple doesn't fall far from the tree
does it and a Florida lawyer argues that
a pregnant inmate's fetus is being
illegally detained this actually could
be a really big deal case all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
oh the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
fund themselves is bad no comment on
that but I do invite you to join us on
the bonus show sign up at joinpakman.com
foreign